let's talk about something really
practical when to take your vitamins
should you take them before bed with a
meal on an empty stomach in the morning
now I'm going to discuss this but I will
say I've been known to be wrong about
this topic sometimes I'll tell people to
take vitamins before bed and all of a
sudden it wakes them up on the other
hand I'll tell people to take vitamins
in the morning and it puts them to sleep
now that's rare but it could happen so
you're gonna have to test things out so
I'm going to give you some general uh
tips to follow it's not absolute but I
think it could be helpful in just
increasing the absorption and the
effectiveness of these remedies there's
two types of vitamins you have the water
soluble and the fat soluble vitamins so
fat soluble vitamins absorb a little bit
better if you take them with fat so if
you took fat soluble vitamins before a
meal for example uh cancers are they're
going to be absorbed a little bit better
but a lot of fat soluble vitamins come
with their own fat they come with either
MCT oil or sometimes they'll come with a
little olive oil but not all always but
that being said let's say you're doing
fasting and you're not eating for
several days just take the vitamins
whenever you can because you're going to
absorb a good amount but the um taking
some fat with a vitamin just helps the
absorption a little bit better so that
would include vitamin A vitamin D
vitamin E vitamin K1 and K2 now most
people don't take vitamin A but they
take cod liver oil to get vitamin A D
and omega-3 fatty acids because all
three of those nutrients
can be better absorbed with oil here's
the thing cod liver oil is not a vitamin
it contains vitamins in an oil omega-3
fatty acid and so vitamin A and vitamin
D are going to be absorbed so you could
realistically take cod liver oil at any
point of the day probably not before bed
but I just wanted to emphasize the
relationship between the fat cyber
vitamins and using some fat while
absorbing them personally I take my cod
liver oil in the morning when uh when I
wake up now let's talk about some of the
exceptions to things like vitamin D3
really helps most people sleep better so
sometimes I'll take vitamin D right
before bed other times I'll just take it
in the early morning because the vitamin
D that I have already comes with its own
fat as well as the the K2 now Vitamin E
for example I recommend if you're going
to take vitamin A take it in the form of
ocotrenals because they just work a lot
better than thecopherols and I don't
recommend getting a mixed between the
tocotrenals and the tocopherol I would
just recommend getting a
complex and that would be a good one to
take with meals now the other thing you
should know is a lot of the
phytonutrients rottenoids
sulforaphane flavonoids are fat soluble
okay this is why it's good to have olive
oil on your salad because you're going
to extract more of these phytonutrients
so if you're taking a phytonutrient
blend whether it's cruciferous Blend or
or maybe some other herb with or cumin
like you're taking turmeric which has
curcumin in there might be a good idea
to take that with a meal so you'll
extract more of that fat soluble
nutrient from that compound even
wheatgrass juice powder if you took that
with a meal you may extract a little bit
more of the carotenoids and other
phytonutrients in that product but for
convenience sake a lot of people take in
the morning and that's totally fine and
then of course some people take it right
before bed and they tend to sleep better
so I'm just pointing out some general
suggestions that you may want to try but
again
there's always lots of exceptions like
some people will forget to take it or
it's not convenient because they are
they're going somewhere and they're
going to be eating and they're not they
don't want to take their vitamins well
just take them in the morning on an
empty stomach it's not a big deal now as
far as uh what else to take right before
a meal uh definitely you want to take
the betaine hydrochloride that's in a
lot of digestive formulas but butane
hydrochloride is in a acidifier so
that's always to be taken right before a
meal and then also if you're taking
enzymes to help you digest like
digestive enzymes take those before a
meal can you take them after the meal
yes you can even take betaine
hydrochloride after the meal like in
Thanksgiving I have a bottle of betaine
hydrochloride or my digestive formula on
the table and so I have found that when
people overeat they can take some of
that after the meal and it helps them
with digestion so there's not this hard
rule that you have to always take it
right before some people take it right
in the middle of the mail the only time
you wouldn't want to take it is if you
have an ulcer or gastritis because
you're going to add an acid to something
that already has too much acid or
something that is kind of an open wound
now one point about bile salts or oxbial
or any products with bile like
gallbladder formula
you may see better benefit if you have
that right after the meal
why is that because
here you are you are digesting all this
food right and if you actually take
um well this is for some people if some
people take this bile salt or bile salt
products before the meal well they may
alkalize their foods to a certain degree
and they might not get the full
digestion but if you have enough stomach
acid it's not going to make a difference
okay this is mainly for people who don't
have enough stomach acid anytime you
take the bile salts and you feel worse
chances are
you need to switch gears and start
adding more acid to the stomach like
butane hydrochloride to build that up
because that could be one of the reasons
why you're not producing enough bile you
don't have the activator the acidifier
the betaine hydrochloride but general
rule of thumb take the betaine
hydrochloride before the meal and the
bile salts after the meal all right what
to take on an empty stomach there's a
really popular or I think should be more
popular a product called Tut cut which
is a type of bile salt a little
different than your typical bile saw but
tutka can help with a lot of different
things I like to recommend it if someone
has bile sludge and they have kind of
like a backup in the bile ducts and they
have like nauseousness or they might
have pain
underneath the right rib cage or the
left rib cage but you can use it for
many different things for dementia
because it crosses the blood-brain
barrier you can use it for issues with
the liver like cirrhosis or Scar Tissue
if you have any weird symptoms that are
not responding I always recommend Tucka
and it seems to work especially if it's
related to digestion that is a good one
to take an empty stomach and I would
probably recommend anywhere between one
or two in the early part of the day and
one or two in the afternoon and empty
stomach if you take them with a meal you
may find that that acts on the fats in
the meal and not on kind of like
clearing out certain type of like
blockages within the system so I
recommend taking in an empty stomach
about at least an hour before meal or an
hour after the meal another one is
activated charcoal if you're detoxifying
you want to take that an empty stomach
another one is bentonite clay as
something to absorb toxins individual
amino acids so let's say you're taking
tryptophan well if you take it with the
meal it's not going to work because
these other Amino from the meal will
compete with tryptophan kind of negates
the effectiveness so take the amino
acids on an empty stomach trace minerals
another good one to take on an empty
stomach but again
I take them in the morning which
actually is on an empty stomach but I
wouldn't uh not tell you to take it with
a meal it could work nicely but here's
the thing about trace minerals like all
minerals when you have better acid in
the stomach and it's not diluted from a
meal you may get a little bit better
absorption because in order to absorb
minerals and trace minerals you need
that hydrochloric acid in a certain
strength so you'll get a little more
absorption if you take your minerals or
trace minerals on empty stomach where
that acid is just like ready to just to
pull it right in and it's not diluted
with any other types of foods the next
point is what should you take before bed
I typically recommend taking your
calcium before bed if you're going to
take calcium and your magnesium before a
bed I don't recommend taking calcium
with your meals because it's an
alkalizer and it can alkalize
the acid to some degree so take that
before you go to bed and the reason you
would take it is either for leg cramps
or help sleep like let's say for example
you're tired but your head is not tired
you're like your head is awake
calcium tends to work for that and
there's many other reasons why they take
calcium but typically I don't recommend
people take a lot of calcium but here
and there but not on a regular basis
especially even your postmenopausal
because it can actually increase your
risk of getting heart attacks magnesium
is a good one to take in the evening
right before bed helps relax you it
helps muscle cramps probiotics are
really good to take before you go to bed
so many people this especially initially
start to detox or have some type of
immune reaction when they take an a
probiotic or even sometimes when they
take colostrum
because it affects the immune system to
a certain degree and it may create a
reaction
increasing histamines and make you a
little bit more tired so if you take it
before bed
you don't know any difference because
you're sleeping now vitamin D3 it helps
me sleep I find with the majority of
people it will help them sleep but not
everyone some people they will make them
stay up so you'll have to test the
waters on that but vitamin D is really
important in the Circadian rhythm and it
can help
like jet lag and resetting your clock
that controls the Circadian wave vitamin
B1 is a good one to take before a bed as
well especially if you're thinking and
analyzing things to death you take the
natural B1 I recommend natural B1 before
bed not the synthetic and you will sleep
a little bit better it also helps
decrease stress also any like
detoxifying herbs I have tried so many
different like remedies to detox myself
and um I always recommend taking it
before bed because if they create that
immune reaction what you're going to
notice is you're just going to sleep
better because they create a little bit
of a histamine response and a little bit
of fatigue so herbs that increase
detoxification like dim which is a
cruciferous extract would be one but
there's many other
you know like kidney detoxifiers or
liver detoxifiers take those at night I
would take that more with um like your
lunch or your meal of the day because it
has a lot of the other phytonutrients
but dim being a concentrated version of
the cruciferous that's more for
detoxifying estrogen that should be
taken before bed now as far as apple
cider vinegar okay if you want to help
your blood sugars in the morning
um you know maybe like an hour before
bed put then a little bit of water and
drink that down
I don't recommend drinking a lot of
water before bed but you get the apple
cider vinegar down or even to take apple
cider vinegar in a pill form it can help
you wake up with better blood sugars you
can even help your sleep I've done
videos on that you can also take apple
cider vinegar with your meals which I
recommend and also even on an empty
stomach with your water like I'll take a
big glass of water probably 20 ounces in
the morning with my apple cider vinegar
by lemon and sometimes I'll add my
electrolyte powder in there and I'll
drink that down with a lot of the
supplements now this is basically
with a meal or without a meal of course
hopefully you're not doing a meal in the
morning so you're fasting but this is
when I would recommend taking your
electrolyte powder because if you take
the electrolyte powder high-end
potassium before bed you might be waking
up urinating a lot because it gets rid
of excessive fluid so I like the
electrolytes in the morning plus
potassium gives you a good amount of
energy that being said it does help
people sleep because it does take a good
amount of energy to help with the sleep
cycles so here I am recommending in the
morning but some people
do the opposite and take it right before
bed and sleep through the night and do
fine and even sometimes people take it
right before they work out to get more
energy we're going to take things that
give you energy like early in the day
right like B12 that would be a good one
to take in the morning any type of herbs
that are stimulatory like uh ginseng
Maca okay these are things that can
increase energy you take those in the
morning so I just wanted to give you uh
some general tips and rules on vitamins
and minerals and other things when you
should take them all right so now that
you learned that now it's time to learn
the nine foods that contain all of your
fat soluble vitamins right here